alors je vais rappeler les faits
cependant comme mardi dernier vous
rencontrez une jeune étudiante avec qui
vous parliez sur instagram c'est ça qui
m'a mis d'accord après avoir passé la
journée avec haine vous l'invitez vous
l'invitez où elle vous invite donc on se
voit tout l'après midi de 16h à jusqu'au
couvre feu la raccompagne pour qu'elle
puisse rentrer chez elle je rentre chez
moi je lui ai écrit en disant que si
elle veut passer prendre un verre sur
les quais en bas de chez moi
elle peut venir elle me dit qu'elle
vient on passe la soirée ensemble et on
voit un film vers minuit un deuxième
film et à un moment donné on couche
ensemble et elle est donc de rang semble
donc vous avez une relation soir et il y
prétendre et le lendemain matin au
moment de partir et m'embrasse d'abord
sur le visage puis sur sur les lèvres
elle part elle aurait écrit pour me dire
qu'elle a oublié ses lunettes si elle
peut passer dans la semaine
elle passe dans la semaine deux jours
plus tard donc le jeudi dernier elle me
dit enfin je lui donne les lunettes elle
me dit voilà je trouve que ça allait un
peu trop vite je sais pas ce qui s'est
passé
tu trouves pas commencé à me parler et
un moment donné bout d'un quart d'heure
de discussion
elle me dit il faut que je dise quelque
chose je suis pas sûr que j'ai fait la
bonne chose à faire mais je suis j'ai
parlé à des amis qui m'ont dit qu'il
fallait que j'aille à la police et est
donc j'ai déposé une main courante à la
police moi j'étais avant de tout régler
c'est humainement en fait pas beau à ce
qu'on avait vécu et par rapport à ce qui
était trop comment elle vous a très
explicite qu'elle a commencé à vous dit
j'ai parlé des amis ni c'était difficile
pour elle de me le dire en fait c'est
assez confus et l'essayer de m
interroger sur la soirée et me disait ce
qu'on avait pensé et ses jeux rapliq a
qu'à tout moment on a été un dialogue en
discussion qu'on s'est demandé si on
voulait coucher ensemble ou pas qu on
s'est embrassés que j'ai d'abord demandé
si elle pouvait passer sa main il me l'a
donné qu elle m'a dit qu'elle aimait
bien le massage que je faisais fin des
cas c'est un peu déroutant pour moi de
vous décrire tout ça
aujourd'hui ça s'est prostituée en mai
mais je pense que c'est important de le
faire parce que parce que ce qui est
important c'est pas l'interaction
humaine qui pour moi est très clair qui
sauvent pas douter vous savez il ya des
rapports qui parfois sont pas
explicitement consenti là il y avait un
élément physique un peu facile de vous
en parler mais d'avc règle donc on
savait pas si si s'il fallait
si on avait envie en fait c'est tout
simplement et donc on en a parlé on a
parlé pendant et même juste avant et on
s'est un moment où s'est dit oui on est
on l'a fait et et pendant qu'on le
faisait voilà enfin
tant qu'à faire parce que c'est en tant
qu à aller jusqu'au bout dans
l'humiliation s'est demandé si ça nous
plaisait mutuellement on sait répondu et
est donc
donc voilà donc là desssus humaine
immédiatement quand il me dit ça l heure
on parle j'ai dit mais pourquoi comment
et cetera elle me dit mais j'ai pas avec
des amis je me sentais mal j'étais chez
moi seule sais pas
elle me demande pardon je comprends
qu'elle qu'elle qu'elle avait vu deux
histoires d'amour avant avant moi donc
que c'était quelque chose pour elle qui
n'était pas forcément innocent de
coucher qu'un garçon comme ça qu'il y
avait il y avait potentiellement des
enjeux je m'excuse de ne pas avoir pris
en compte cet élément demande pardon a
dit qu'elle va retirer la main courante
jeudi mais vous savez c'est moi en fait
je pense que vous vous rendez pas compte
que c'est moi et que nécessairement et
le lendemain matin adjoint du parisien
m'appelle me dit vous savez tout le
monde est au courant donc autant que ce
soit nous qui sortons une enquête pénale
a été ouverte contre vous pour pour viol
alors sa version la version de la
plaignante
après partout dans la presse elle
convient d'un rendez vous entre vous il
y avait chez ordures est suggéré de
regarde un film quand vous dites dans sa
chambre la jeune femme est également
évoqué le fait qu'il y ait eu
consommation de drogues à votre domicile
il m'a proposé de la maline à nokia
s'est terminée nous en avons pris vous
savez ce que c'est de la magie ne sais
pas du tout c'est quoi fait un que de
l'iprem mais là comment je ne connais
pas du tout c'est un cachet de la manne
insee qui vend de 2co doliprane mais
comment est-ce qu'on se voit ça cogne un
peu plus quand j'ai eu le champ de
bosses
moi j'en ai un vrai médicament ce n'est
pas innocent moi j'en ai parce que je me
suis coupé le doigt et on a créé ce cri
d'en prendre 10 par jour
c'est alors que douleur on en a pris
mais quoi pour qu'on a appris à un
ennemi ensemble parce que d'élire en
fait ça fait parce qu'on est des enfants
en fait et parce que on avait parlé tout
l'après-midi soit au jardin du
luxembourg etc on ait parlé de ce qu'est
ce qu'on est ce qu'on a déjà pris des
drogues est ce qu'on a fait est ce qu'on
buvait tous les dons étaient un peu ils
ne se rendent là non pas trop elle nous
dit j'ai fait du ballon une fois moins
cher parce que c'était elle m'explique
moi j'ai dit j'ai pris des champignons
hallucinogènes
une fois voilà et est en fait dans le
jeu érotique il a dit je comprends même
pas pourquoi ça devient un sujet de
discussion je trouve ça assez violent
donc à un moment donné on n'a rien on
n'a jamais acheté de drogue qui les a ni
moi on n'a pas envie d'en acheter on n'a
pas envie de participer à ça moi j'ai
jamais touché à aucune drogue dure à
côté mais qu'est ce que ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que quand vous êtes
engagé politiquement que quand vous êtes
en confrontation directe avec le pouvoir
faites vous devenez une cible deux
façons soit explicité volontaires
instrumental soi et donc tous les
journaux reprendre prennent ça pour en
fait ne faire passer et nous faire
passer pour un drogué après une soirée
bien on va on va revenir sur la fermer
il ya un truc qui qui est accroc avec à
chaque fois que je parle de vous moi on
me dit il est très sympa juan branco
c'est un mec est brillant mais il a une
obsession c'est gabriel atta le porte
parole du gouvernement avec qui vous
étiez à l'école et xavier niel
si vous avez créé aussi un livre mais
surtout gabriel atteint avec qui vous
étiez à l'école j'avais fait une
fixation sur lui vous fait une fixette
sur lui moi je suis venu ici pour pour
vous dire une chose j'ai quand quand
j'avais 26 ans j'avais été invité 27 ans
était un mois avant les gilet jaune
j'avais invité par bernard arnault nous
aligner les compagnies à l'inauguration
de la boutique louis vuitton
classe en sommes d'accord d'accord donc
j'étais allé qu'une personne je ne vais
peut-être retrouver au dîner là-bas avec
plein de très belles actrices mannequins
plaintes rentes plein de gens très
riches très intéressant etc il m'avait
mis à la place avec tous les to pendant
une table où il ya donc au ritz avec des
serveurs en livrée avec des vins
extrêmement cher et c'est avec huit
directeurs de rédaction de rédaction est
très sympathique et ces messieurs au
mieux vise in et j'ai demandé un peu
comme ça mais mais comment ça se fait
que vous êtes là en fait qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que
pourquoi pourquoi des dites pourquoi
bernard arnault xavier d'un final nous
tous a invité des journalistes et
pourquoi vous acceptez d'être invité à
un événement commercial et vous êtes là
comme si de rien n'était
dans ce petit entre eux soit donc je
demande juste mais en fait qu'est ce que
vous faites là ça serait sans arrière
pensée en corse en avoir une et ils me
répondent ils me répondent pas en fait
rien sinon ce qui se fait et gêné dans
la table alors ça se passait bien
jusqu'à l'heure de constance bnq est
aujourd'hui produit que par dont le
talent la directrice de leur pôle
lagardère lagardère média et ainsi de
suite elle est à côté de moi elle rigole
et à l'époque a dirigé l nahla sauf que
là je sens une gêne importante est en
fait lâche me rends compte qu'il ya
quelque chose qui se passe en france qui
n'est pas du tout normal qui en fait
l'emprise qu'un certain d'oligarques de
personnes ont sur les médias donc ici on
est chez bolloré quand vous allez sur
mais dans les faits même si on avait
juste on est chez boulanger vous voyez
bien qu'on vous invite ce soir donc mais
moi j'ai jamais attaqué bolloré je pense
que les nations ça c'est une chose et
d'autre part je pense que vu la façon
dont jusqu'au issus des fois d'avant
vous savez je trouve c'est plutôt une
preuve de courage de ma part d'être ici
qu autre chose quand vous avez été mal
reçu les parents de ce qu'on avait
attaqué également sur sur le rapport à
un beau lauréat sur mon contrat vous
êtes fallu libérer du plateau vous aviez
donné des faux chiffres voilà non j'ai
donné les chiffres du contrat ou pas les
bons chiffres de salaire à parvenir à la
rue mais il savait pas de vous avez dit
que c'était mon salaire non voilà
j'aurai voilà c'était donc c'est un
point sensible jeudi rosa qu'on s'était
approché mais on aurait pu très bien
vous dire tout ce que je veux dire par
là c'est revenu sur la gt gt jusqu alors
très protégé très intégrés ainsi de
suite et à partir du moment où j'ai
commencé à me détacher à poser ces
questions à dire c'est pas normal qu'ils
essayaient à cessieu parce que du coup
c'est à dire que le reste des français
voient la réalité à travers un voile
parce qu'en fait il ya une petite entre
eux soit qu'ils fabriquent l'information
et ya le reste des français qui sont pas
au courant de ces liens de qui est
propriétaire de quoi de qui dînent
acquis
ces appartenances l inverse
à partir de là j'ai commencé à mettre en
branle et en lutte j'écris un livre qui
a eu aucun média comme il l'a rappelé
qui s'est très bien vendu crépuscule qui
justement dénoncer ce système je me suis
engagé auprès de gilet jaune j'ai
commencé à me battre à leurs côtés et
évidemment la perception qui en ce qui
me concerne a commencé à s'inverser et
évidemment la moindre chose qui vous
être instrumentalisée contre -
commencent à être utilisés si je te
connais pas beaucoup il finit juste
d'être je connais pas beaucoup d'avocats
en france et à partir ce qu'à partir de
là en fait ce qui s'est construit ça a
été une vraie lutte avec le régime
actuel je connais pas beaucoup de
d'avocats en france qui ai gagné un
procès contre emmanuel brigitte macro
qui je le rappelle pardonnez moi je
finis là-dessus vraiment je vous promets
avait poursuivi et ça personne ne sait
pourquoi la fpt présente n'a pas fait
des pêches
un sdf parce qu'il avait barboter avec
un homard géant face au fort de
brégançon pour se [ __ ] de leur gueule
et ils ont fait des poursuites pénales
qui ont fait que des normes et des
procédures pour viol pour violences
conjugales ont été décalés pour traiter
ses locaux et pau donc si justement
j'aimerais comprendre pourquoi ces
digressions là qui semble être pour vous
une sorte de justification de la sphère
en question est en train de nous
expliquer en gros il ya une cabale
contre moi et ça donne finalement
peut-être et instrumentalisant jamais je
n'irai jamais à moi j'irai jamais un mot
je dirai jamais un mot sur cette jeune
fille de négatif parce que ce que j'ai
fait ce que j'ai passé avec elle deux
boutons bout à une expérience
humainement très intense qu y compris
lorsqu'elle est revenue vers moi pour me
pour me dire ce qu'elle m'avait dit j'ai
pas du tout pensé aux conséquences en
termes d'image publique de 2 par rapport
à la police tout ça gt gt dans un
rapport de 2 ressenti de violence très
fort par rapport à ce que je trouve être
une trahison de l'intimité et
l'explication qu'elle m'a donné à
l'époque et le mouvement qu'elle a fait
et où elle m'a annoncé qu'elle qu'elle
retirait la main courante et c'est parce
que je ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé
mais en tout cas ce que je par contre ce
que j'explique c'est comment ça se fait
que de là ça devient un sujet national
que tous les médias en boucle commence à
parler à raconter quelque chose sur la
base de rien sur la base de rien et c
est là et là je fais le lien en effet
avec tout ce que j'ai racontée jusqu'ici
c'est que sur ce prime car jamais jamais
je n'essaierai de justifier un
comportement ou quelque chose qui puisse
atteindre intérêts d'une personne plus
fragile que man ou une femme en général
c'est pas forcément sur la base de rien
qui a une plaignante qui avait fait un
enseignant courante c'est infini qui dit
quand même que la la maline a été
absorbé la manne il faut savoir que
c'est quelque chose qui peut qui peut ça
contient de l'opium de la caféine ou des
paracétamols non mais c'est juste pour
dire c'est quelque chose du parlement la
canton l'absorbent ça peut rendre soit
dépendant ou soit euphorique donc c'est
pas immense favorite c'est dans les
effets secondaires c'est assez violent
et à l'euphorie
c'est quelque chose qu'ils aient la
manifestation non mais c'est pas
innocent forcément aux citations
après ça peut être que quelqu'un devient
vulnérable c'est pour ça que le signal
est simplement allée elle-même elle a
ressenti des fêtes d'accord et l'a dit
elle même
vous ne pouvez pas ressentir d'effets
quand vous prenez un cachet de co2 ni
prime moi j'ai compris ce délire je
voulais vous demander
voilà je voulais vous demander quand
même peut-être parce qu'ici on prend des
rails de coke sans difficulté moi j'en
ai jamais autre que oui c'est vrai
j'aimerais bien mais je suis en place ou
non mais attendez il ya un moment il
faut arrêter
vous êtes en train de jouer avec moi de
chanter de connaître la cua donc si on
part et vous allez encore mieux dater
vision avec du miel de télévision non
mais tu parle de moi mais pourquoi vous
semblez madrid pourquoi tu parles comme
ça à deux rails de coke l'épreuve la
santé vise est gérée personne n'a pris
de la banque personnel craint des
drogues dures dans le temps de saisir
pourquoi aider des projets de presse que
je parle de seurre tous tombés dans mais
là c'est pas bien mais sinon pourquoi
est-ce que je parle de ça mais c'est pas
bien j'en parle de ça parce que la pièce
qu'on essaie d'enseigner ou vous veniez
h au fait vous êtes sur le banc des
accusés et vous auriez musée maison je
suis sur le banc des accusés bah oui
vous êtes sur le banc des accusés la
justice qui a porté pendant la bagarre
dès aujourd'hui c'est parce que j'ai
parlé de pourquoi est-ce que j'ai pas de
la question des drogues c'est la raison
pourquoi pourquoi est-ce que j'en ai
parlé
est-ce que je peux dire un mot parce que
ce qu'on essaie je sais même pas fume un
joint de poissons plus apparaître
demande c'est quoi ce délire de la manic
je voulais rester pour un essai d'un si
nos élites ou sait pas qui est ce qu'on
essaye d'insinuer à travers ça c'est que
je n'ai g drogué une jeune femme vous
couchez avec m
abbas était sûr que c'est ça quand vous
demandiez normal de vols ont été
utilisés et donc moi ce que j'essaie
d'expliquer c'est qu'on parle d'un co2
ni prime on parle de quelque chose qu'on
a fait ensemble après en avoir
longuement parlé lui est là de l'épreuve
du nid et d'autant de co2 ni pratiqué
par dépendance à l'opium non non non
j'ai calculé
j'ai calculé épouse olivia les maisons
perdues 12 pas de la maline à n'apporter
% à 2 % des jeunes il orientera sur quel
est l'intérêt
c'est normal de poser la question
monsieur c'est normal que vos questions
gérad il est normal que je récupère un
pas vers vous parce que je pense qu'il
est effectivement née dans une époque où
le regret du lendemain donc là
aujourd'hui pourrait devenir un viol
mais ça devient très dangereux
en revanche quand même je veux dire
aussi que quand on est une jeune fille
on a droit de pénétrer dans
l'appartement quelqu'un qu'on connaît
pas ou connaît qu'on connaît depuis peu
qu'on est pas obligé de prendre de la
maline quand quelqu'un vous en donne
n'est pas obligé de coucher avec
quelqu'un qui a pris là la maline sous
prétexte qu on peut aussi dire non
donc effectivement cette jeune fille
visiblement elle n'a pas dit non elle a
dit oui j'ai fait mais je venais un
ballon mais pas une jeune fille enfin là
aussi
elle a 20 ans j'aime aussi mafia a dit
ça pour moi c'est une jeune femme
une chose est ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression malgré tout être l'arroseur
arrosé rapport apa minsky puisque malgré
tout vous avez vous êtes finalement le
nouveau griveaux cette affaire puisque
vous vous avez finalement si vous avez
carrément montrer la nuit dit et
griveaux vous avez dit que c'était
immonde c'était dégueulasse et
finalement vous finalement vous vous
reconnaissez un boomerang à sathonay moi
j'ai défendu une personne qui dit de
montrer le contenu leur grille onu dans
sa laideur je demande une expertise
psychiatrique de monsieur griveaux pour
examiner la nature de ces pathologies
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas dire la même
chose des vingt peut mettre les choses à
plat tranquillement deux choses moi je
suis avocat d'accord absolument j'ai
écrit un livre donc crépuscule dans
laquelle je raconte comment ces
personnes non comment son arrivée au
pouvoir
donc je parle notamment de benjamin
griveaux de quel a été son parcours et
ainsi de suite je parle aussi diabré
natale pas parce que j'étais un
quelconque intérêt pour gabriel ou une
quelconque haine vis-à-vis gabriel
ensemble vous le détestez de légumes et
non ça c'est ce que raconte encore une
fois c'est ce que racontent les médias
pour essayer de créer une image et aucun
aucune difficulté ou appréciation
particulière pour calmer at-elle
d'ailleurs j'ai dû enquêter sur lui
comme sur benjamin griveaux comme sur un
manuel mâcon pour comprendre ce qu'avait
été sa vie j'étais pas au courant de ce
qu'ils étaient devenus depuis
depuis cette période là ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose j'étais
l'avocat personnes d'accord on a essayé
de créer une confiant le même le même
journaliste qui aujourd'hui a essayé de
sortir la lame à nîmes pour le
transformer en dragueur violeur et c'est
quelqu'un qui s'appelle l'asie zemmouri
avait été à l'origine à l'époque des
rumeurs comme quoi j'avais participé à
l'acte et avaient essayé en effet de
coincer benjamin je les dis très
clairement je n'ai pas participé à cette
action de pahlen ce qui est venu vers
moi parce que je suis reconnue comme
étant en lutte contre 1 mcnish s'est dit
que je serai un bon avocat et j'ai
réussi à lui éviter le passage par la
case prison qui aurait était délétère en
à la veille d'un confinement et j'ai
fait mon travail je les fais
gratuitement et j'ai fait avec honneur
et promis d ça c'est très important pour
moi que je raconte ça n'a rien à voir on
va enfin ces deux choses qui n'ont rien
la dernière question qu'est ce qui va se
passer maintenant ça c'est aussi ce qui
est intéressant après
l'instrumentalisation médiatique vient
l'instrumentalisation judiciaire et
policière on en est à dire que
alors ils n'ont pas commencé l'enquète
ils n'ont pas commencé enquête les
fuites viennent du parquet les ch'tites
souviennent du parquet et de la police
et un jour c'est toujours comme mais
pourquoi ne met pas pourquoi depuis
toujours
en quoi est-ce est normal qu'une fuite à
la presse mais ce n'est pas la première
c'est vrai alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on
s'intéresse à moi on se demande bien
mais ça non mais dis donc tu première
phase première phase la fuite vient du
parquet pourtant le parquet s'est
empressé à l'idée de faire savoir
cette histoire de faire savoir les
détails et d'essayer de trouver dans la
déclaration d'un main courante où il n'y
à rien à part le fait qu'on ait pris de
la maline annonce qu'elle a dû décrire
en fait en disant juste qu'est ce qui
s'est passé au cours de la soirée en
répondant aux questions de policiers on
sort cela pour essayer d'en faire déjà
un procès à charge pourquoi parce qu'ils
voient que la première réaction des gens
c'est à dire mais c'est quoi cette
histoire
pourquoi j'ai dû tout d'un coup on est
donc parti à t'accueillir une fille
encore mais non elle m'a écrit pour me
dire qu'elle quelques heineken retire
est qu'il est confirmé que vous qu'elle
voulait retirer la main courante etc et
je ne vais pas être en interaction
qu'elle j'ai pas envie d'être dans un
rapport de pression d'inquiétudes quant
à elle par le vendredi soir après être
venu me voir et me dit est ce que tu
penses qu'on quoi est-ce que vous pensez
que tu veux que vous qu'on pourra rester
en contact malgré cette histoire moi je
ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire
je sais pas ce que je suis pas dans dans
l'esprit de cette personne là j'ai pas
envie qui lui arrive quoi que ce soit à
cause de cette affaire
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de voir que le
parquet est très diligent pour faire
fuiter les éléments qui le rend
intéressant mais ils ne font qu'un
acteur enquête en règle nous n'aurons
pas ils ne vont pas c'est une cabale
contre vous c'est une machination sais
je veux juste que les français se
rendent compte en jeu juste que les
français se rendent compte de comment se
fabrique l'information dans ce pays et
qu'est-ce qui sort et qu'est ce qui ne
serait pas assez c'est juste ça et
j'écris sur ce sujet longuement et je
pense que ça sert d'exemple pour
comprendre que parfois tout d'un coup on
a intérêt à faire monter des affaires
aujourd'hui connus lors de paris a
ouvert une enquête pour viol oui il nous
fait qu'ils n'ont fait aucun acte manqué
ils s'en fichent la paix comment ils
vont faire ça ils vont perdurer
m'attendais pas à une odeur attendez
vous faire vous fait fuiter dans la
presse immédiatement que vous allez
interroger deux matches à nation art et
essai ça vous allez tout de suite
interrogé des personnes vous allez tout
est loué une maison tempête dernier
non pas qu'ils y subissent et il m'a pas
fait d'analysés toxicologiques qui n'ont
rien fait en fait ils vont évidemment
laissé durer pendant des mois pour
laisser une sorte de doute ou
d'impression que quelqu'un qui en effet
en opposition directe avec le pouvoir
politique actuel serait éventuellement
cette partie il ne faut pas il ne faut
pas il ne faut pas prétendre que cela
n'existe pas je ne l'utiliserai jamais
pour me défausser d'une quelconque
société au contraire gg je n'attendais
qu'une chose c'est que ça aille vite et
que je puisse m'expliquer contre puisque
et une confrontation est séparé j'ai dit
tout de suite même pas publiquement
parce que j'ai pas envie pendant son
oreille distraite à faire le constat
n'est pas révélé quel est votre dernier
mot que les rien d'autre que les gens
comprennent que ce qu'ils reçoivent de
fonctionnement politique de ce pays
n'est pas la façon dont se fabrique
réellement des institutions et vous et
vous et vous aussi
une prochaine fois qu'on revenait sur un
plateau la première fois vous dites que
je gagne 250 millions d'euros non j'ai
dit que vous aviez un contrat de 250
millions d'euros avec votre femme
entreprise de la cocaïne
ici jeune fille quelques uns à avoir vu
ou dans la voix là il m'a les choses
comme ça ici il ya que si vous voulez et
je vous dis ça ferait ça vous ferait du
bien aussi de côtoyer des gens comme ça
ou non une enquête sur moi very sais pas
me dire que tout le monde et on avoue
non non j'ai rompu avec je pense que le
monde ne touche pas à mon poste c'est
beaucoup plus simple vous devez quand
j'entends vos histoires parce que nous
ne connaît pas ces histoires de la manie
nous ne sais pas quoi ces conneries mais
en tout cas voilà merci
[Applaudissements]